15 days to slow the spread that is what
we were all told
1032 days ago and nevertheless President
Joe Biden has just announced that the
government will be extending the covid
public health emergency order for the
12th time for another 90 days after
which time I'm sure the government will
let the order expire right
fool me once shame on you fool me twice
shame on me for me hundreds and hundreds
of times
and I'm not sure we have any capacity
for shame left I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yes it is from Dominic zelenak
who says 15 hours ago in and out burger
is preparing for California's Crackdown
on beef with vegan and Cricket based
meat options that's so true you're so
right it's not just that in and out
burger is fleeing the high taxes and the
high regulations and the broadly
anti-christian sort of uh ethos that
you're seeing in California it's also
this whole great reset thing is coming
for in and out baby this hole you will
eat the bugs and you will like it thing
it is coming for your favorite fast food
Burger time to flee quickly before
before you were forced to grill up some
double doubles it doesn't sound good at
all okay I want to get back to good old
America all right that's why
you gotta check out four Patriots a tree
branch hit a power line in Ohio 2003. it
shut down 21 power plants around 100
people died we have a power grid that
was designed in the 1800s even the White
House sees it White House is saying
two-thirds of the grid is at least 25
years old so they recently announced
billions of dollars to update it how
long is that going to take very long
time that's why having your own solar
power is more important than ever with
the four Patriots Patriot power
generator you get a portable solar
generator that does not install into
your house you can take it with you
wherever you go the four Patriots
Patriot power generator is powerful
enough for your phones medical devices
even your fridge right now you can go to
fourpatriots.com use code Knolls to get
10 off your first purchase on anything
in the store you will also get their
famous guarantee for an entire year
after your order plus free shipping on
orders over ninety seven dollars portion
of every sale is donated to charities
who support our veterans and their
families go to fourpatriots.com use code
Knowles Canada wlas to get 10 off that
is for patriots.com use code nulls
k-n-out-w-l-e-s to get yours and be
prepared today
I don't know if you'd know this but Joe
Biden is not an honest man
he's not I know that the covid lockdown
stuff did not begin under Joe Biden but
it has extended apparently indefinitely
under under Joe Biden and you could see
after Trump announced the 15 days to
slow the spread he then tried to take it
back
you could see him trying to take the
power back from Dr fauci trying to take
the power back from the libs trying to
take the power back from the World
Health Organization the CDC and everyone
who was shutting down our whole society
remember he suggested in 2020 maybe we
can reopen the country by Easter
wouldn't that be good and we were all
excited for that but unfortunately once
he had given that power and that
influence away
it proved impossible to get it back and
now Joe Biden doesn't want to take it
away Joe Biden wants to mandate the
vaccines for everybody Joe Biden wants
to keep the country in a state if not of
lockdown then at least of emergency
measures where the government can lock
you down whenever it wants to and and
they're going to keep doing this Joe
Biden do you remember when he became
president he said who were headed for a
winter of death and darkness oh yeah
baby he seemed so excited because he
knew that it would give him more and
more power so okay Joe Biden now says
only 90 more days of the emergency
lockdown yeah okay sure thing if you
believe that then I have got a bridge in
Brooklyn to see you don't forget Joe
Biden had to drop out of his first
presidential run specifically for lying
and he is all politicians lie or most
most politicians lie but Joe Biden lies
a lot more and a lot more egregiously
than most of them
he lied about the man who was involved
in the car accident that killed his wife
he I mean he lied about really really
awful personal things he he lied about
his academic record he has lied about
his political record he's lied about it
all and now apparently he lied about the
classified documents that he was hiding
in his private office so we talked about
this yesterday after the Democrats have
spent weeks and weeks and weeks making a
huge hullabaloo about how Donald Trump
had classified documents and they could
potentially endanger sources and get
people killed it's this horribly selling
State secrets and it was so egregious
that the FBI had to go kick down the
door practically at Mar-A-Lago raid the
former president's home they're talking
about Prosecuting Donald Trump well then
it turned out Joe Biden did exactly the
same thing in fact what Joe Biden did
his worse because it turned out Joe
Biden had a bunch of classified
documents in a private office of his in
a closet in a private office just like
Donald Trump did
but the difference was Trump had the
legal right to declassify whatever
documents he wanted as President Joe
Biden when he took those documents and
we stored them for years and years he
did not have that right because Joe
Biden had only been the vice president
so we talked about the documents that
were found turns out
there's another Trove of documents that
were just found
mishandled by Joe Biden we don't know
exactly where the the other batch of
documents were the first batch were in
Joe Biden's private office at his fake
think tank but but the the new one we
just don't know but we do know that
they're classified and we do know that
the government is going in now and
taking these documents so to be as Fair
as I possibly can presumably
Joe Biden could declassify all of these
documents now
so
it's the same principle that we're
applying to Donald Trump as president of
the United States Joe Biden could say
right now the wave of his magic wand
these documents are Declassified there
is no higher authority that Joe Biden
has to appeal to to declassify documents
because he's the commander-in-chief he's
the president of the United States he's
the top of the executive branch if Joe
Biden had to go to some middling
bureaucrat to say excuse me will you
approve my declassification order then
that would completely undermine his
constitutional role as president of the
United States however
when Biden took those documents
and for the years and years what was it
something like five years in which Joe
Biden was storing those documents
he did not have the right to do that
that was illegal that was much much
worse than what Trump did and so we've
now got three data points on this we've
got
Donald Trump had documents at Mar-A-Lago
Joe Biden had classified documents at
his private offices and Hillary Clinton
had lots and lots of classified
documents on her email server
Hillary's was probably the most
egregious Hillary was not the vice
president of the United States she was
Secretary of State and the documents
were not old documents that she took
from her time in government they were
current documents and the documents
weren't locked up in a closet in a
physical form where it would be very
hard to take them or create copies of
them they were on an easily hacked
server and if any of those episodes were
going to get people killed it certainly
would be Hillary Clinton's what happened
to Hillary nothing not so much as a slap
on the wrist Joe Biden improperly soared
last five documents that he had no right
to declassify for years and years and
years highly sensitive could reveal
sources and methods what's going to
happen to Joe Biden absolutely nothing
Donald Trump takes some souvenir
documents from his time in the white
house documents that he had 100
authority to declassify what happens the
FBI raids this house so I just don't
want to hear it okay I think we can now
firmly conclude that this issue of the
classified documents has nothing to do
with principle it has nothing to do with
real National Security threats is simply
about punishing political enemies
Hillary does it Hillary does the worst
version of it no big deal no slap on the
wrist doesn't matter
Biden does a pretty bad version of it no
big deal brush it under the rug nothing
to see her move along Move Along Donald
Trump does the version of it that is
most defensible and
hardest to claim is illegal in any way
it's the end of the world Americans are
being killed overseas we're giving away
the nuclear secrets this man needs to go
into an orange jumpsuit
and and now that this happened to Biden
you're going to see the news move right
along no big deal nothing to see here
okay this is just about punishing
political enemies you know this is the
case because the White House is dodging
questions on this issue like Neo in The
Matrix okay the Korean Jean-Pierre poor
lady I hope she can I hope she can bend
to the side the right way because the
questions are pretty straightforward the
issue is pretty clear and she is dodging
them as fast as she can on these
documents how could anyone be that
irresponsible isn't that what this
President says about mishandling
classified documents the president spoke
to this personally he spoke to this
personally he again he believes that
classified documents and information
should be taken seriously he takes them
seriously and he was surprised to learn
by any any records I disagree I disagree
here's what happened here's what
happened once the history of justice
department well let me let me explain to
you the process here's what happened
when his lawyers found out that the
documents were there they immediately
turn them over to their archives how can
President Biden be trusted moving
forward with American Secrets because
his lawyers his team did the right thing
but he had a closet with he classified
employers did the right again again
again
he was surprised that the records were
there he spoke to this personally he was
surprised that the pr that the records
were there and when his lawyers found
out and his team found out that they
were there they turned it over to their
archives and now it's being reviewed by
the Department of Justice
oh he was surprised that the records
were there
okay then okay then no big deal
do I believe that Joe Biden was actually
surprised that the records were there
maybe he's a liar so I'm inclined not to
believe him but he's pretty forgetful so
I'm somewhat inclined to believe him
either way though he was surprised that
the records were there is no excuse
intention can matter when we're talking
about Prosecuting crimes
but if the action that is taken
intentionally or unintentionally is an
egregious action if it's against the law
then there has to be some punishment for
it right for the action itself not
merely the intention the road to hell is
paved with good intentions think about
the distinction between murder and
manslaughter yes it's true that we
prosecute murder more severely than we
prosecute manslaughter but we prosecute
manslaughter why because it's wrong to
kill a person whether you intend to kill
a person or not so is it wrong to
mishandle these classified documents or
is it not
well he just he didn't he didn't intend
to ignorance of the law is not an excuse
ignorance of your own actions is not an
excuse either not ultimately and so
you're going to see the libs move on
from this
and it's going to expose what the Trump
classified documents episode the walls
are closing in they've got him now of
2022 was really all about it was just a
bunch of nonsense to punish a political
enemy in fact not only are you going to
see these sorts of excuses for Joe
Biden's Behavior you already are seeing
them and you're not just seeing them
from his paid spokesman you're not
already seeing them from
just from the White House Press
Secretary you're seeing them from The
Establishment media you are seeing it
from Joy Behar on The View on The View
joy joy Vejar on The View we will get to
Joy Behar in just one second first
though I I'd prefer to learn something
speaking of ignorance I I would like to
be educated that's why you got to check
out Legacy learning right now head on
over to
richdadworld.com
Knowles well I want that to be my new
nickname Rich daddy Rich daddy Knowles
you got to check out Rich Dad world it's
an online program led by the world
famous author Robert Kiyosaki Robert
Kiyosaki author of the top selling
personal finance book Rich Dad Poor Dad
is on a mission to elevate the financial
well-being of humanity his upcoming free
live stream event where Robert and a
team of trusted investors will go over
their 2023 predictions is his most
popular event of the year you are
getting access to one of the most elite
teams of investors Market leaders and
economists in the world for free
regardless of your experience level you
can learn to boost your monthly cash
flow and achieve your dreams of
Financial Freedom if you want to learn
what smart investors are doing in 2023
listen to the number one personal
finance author of all time for free head
on over to richdadworld.com
for free access to Robert
hockey's 2023 predictions live stream
plus listeners to this podcast get a
free copy of Robert's new book before it
is even released to the public and a
recorded coaching session valued at 200
for free head on over to
richdadworld.com get your free book and
free access to the 2023 predictions live
stream event one last time that is
richdadworld.com Knowles
Joy Behar on The View
says that this situation with Biden
improperly storing classified documents
it's completely different from what
Donald Trump did here's why
Barney's calmed down a little bit
because there are some perhaps
differences here the Optics are not
necessarily the best
so is it good news for you know who
anything that makes us talk about him is
good news for him not really I mean I I
think that no matter what you just said
is right that there are differences in
what happened yes it's not good well we
all know that Trump is a liar and a
thief you know we know that
so it's not that big a jump to say that
he obstructed and he lied we don't think
that Biden is a liar and a thief so we
give him the benefit of the doubt that's
probably what's going on
that's what's going on right now I know
I know people are going to
pull their hair out in indignation and
shock at the absurdity of Joy behar's
statement that Joe Biden he's not a liar
and a thief
job put thieving aside I mean he seems
pretty crooked to me but he is a liar
he's probably the most infamous liar
politician alive today
not a cheap shot I'm not just trying to
throw a bomb at my political opponent I
mean specifically for lying he's been
caught in it the most he's had the most
political consequence in his life
because he's a liar Democrats call him a
liar Republicans call him a Liars but
put that aside for a second the
principle that Joy Behar is espousing
here is
we give more grace to people on our own
side than we do to our enemies and to
our political opponents
that's a pretty smart principle actually
there's nothing wrong with that
principle
there's nothing hypocritical
it's not that there's a double standard
even with that kind of a principle
that is politics
politics is a team sport
politics begins with the premise that
man is a social animal and we find our
identity and our flourishing in society
with one another and when you're in
Democratic politics and Republican
politics such as we are then there are
going to be different coalitions that
form to get things done now a man is an
island you can't do politics all by
yourself and so you form coalitions and
it is Perfectly Natural to have more
trust in the people who are close to you
it is Perfectly Natural to give the
benefit of the doubt or more of the
benefit of the doubt to people who are
part of your team part of your family
part of your community your fellow
countrymen it is a liberal lie and error
that that says that we should not afford
any more grace or trust to our own
countrymen than to anybody else on Earth
it is it is a fundamental political
error that comes out of the lips I'm not
just saying the modern left-wing
liberals I'm talking about liberal
modernity I'm talking about the last
several hundred years that says oh no
all these things like loyalty to family
loyalty to tribe you often hear tribal
politics that's the worst thing in the
world well people are in tribes aren't
they people do come from families and
tribes and Nations and it's natural to
have a kind of affection for that and to
offer some Grace to that the family is a
natural Human Institution and political
communities
progress naturally from that patriotism
is a logical extension of filial piety I
have no problem with with Joy Behar
saying yeah look Biden's on my team and
so I trust him more than I trust the guy
on the other team I wish conservatives
want to understand that a little bit
better there's nothing wrong with
preferring your family to somebody
else's family there's nothing wrong with
preferring your country to somebody
else's country
everyone else on Earth operates that way
it's only these these benighted liberals
in the west who have thrown all out that
out the window and said that no human
beings are all just undifferentiated
individuals floating in The Ether
somehow we're all citizens of the world
Kumbaya no that's not true it's not not
how politics works it's not how human
nature works so anyway enough about
Biden's documents Biden is trying to
turn this news cycle around the way he's
going to turn it around is by visiting
the Border
showing that he's getting really tough
on illegal immigration
and Biden tweets out quote our problems
at the border did not arise overnight
and they won't be solved overnight
translation I'm not actually going to do
anything about this but I want to seem
really serious I'm going to go visit the
border for the first time certainly
since he's been president I think maybe
for the first time in his entire
political career he's done some
drive-bys by border towns I'm not sure
the man has ever actually been down to
the Border proper until now
he says
we can come together to fix this broken
system we can ensure the border secure
the Border rather and fix the
immigration process to be orderly fair
safe and humane
there's a real irony about the photo
that he posts
is a photo
features exactly three unique elements
features himself
features
border agents border patrol agents and
it features the wall
he's he's taking the picture
in front of two things that this man has
vilified throughout his presidency do
you remember early on in the Biden
Administration he attacked the border
patrol agents for allegedly riding
around on horses and and using a whip to
Scourge the poor illegal aliens trying
to get across which by the way if you or
I or anybody else broke into another
country that had a big immigration
problem
you could expect that other country to
use that sort of a measure similar
measures to keep us out but for us to
ever try to secure the border that would
be shocking and and when you saw the
image he said well maybe it I don't know
maybe it sort of looks like he's using a
whip but I just don't buy that we we
allow 2 million illegal aliens to flood
into the country every single year I
don't think that there are border agents
like Indiana Jones using whips all along
the border and of course it turned out
it was not true it was a complete
calumny from Joe Biden that the thing
that looked like a whip was just the
reins of the horse the guy was just
trying to ride his horse as it was
bucking up and down
so he vilifies the Border agents
until they're convenient for him of
course he vilifies the wall oh my
goodness has there been has there been
any greater object from the Trump
administration of the Democrats I or
then the wall oh my goodness they hated
that wall
until it's convenient so what does this
picture tell us
it tells us
that Joe Biden believes
that the American people want to secure
the Border it tells us that Joe Biden
believes that the wall is popular with
the American people tells us Joe Biden
believes that border patrol agents are
popular with the American people and the
Democrats will say otherwise they will
say no the majority of Americans want
there to be 10 zillion immigrants every
year no no the majority of Americans
they hate that border wall
that's why we're not gonna they'll say
this at their donor Retreats they'll say
this at their rallies we're not going to
build any more wall the wall is evil but
we're going to abolished Border
Protection and all the cops and we're
going to accept
actions speak louder than words
or even more precisely a picture says a
thousand words and so the picture that
Joe Biden chooses to present is of him
getting tough on the border with the
agents with the wall and problem is
pictures and politicians can be
deceiving and so what Joe Biden is
trying to do here is to deceive people
he's not going to build any more wall
the president of Mexico amlo just came
out and said he was so happy that Joe
Biden hadn't built one extra foot of of
border wall he's not going to actually
do anything about it he's going to
continue to undermine border patrol but
he is going to push that image out there
for the public
because he knows that his policy is in
opposition to what the American people
actually want
and Republicans are mercifully finally
wonderfully starting to do something
about it specifically on this issue
the con Conservative Republican
representative Pat Fallon has just filed
articles of impeachment against border
security or border secretary
Alejandro mayorcas so this is the
Secretary of Homeland Security who's in
charge of the Border uh he is now uh had
articles of impeachment introduced
against him now
what are you going to impeach the guy
for
don't forget
I'm with Joy Behar on this principle I
think we we should be tougher on our
opponents than we are on our friends
I'm not one of these squishy
conservatives who says well you know
it's actually it would be terribly
unprincipled if we were to uh focus more
political ire on our enemies who want to
destroy us in the country than on our
friends who are doing their best to help
but sometimes screw up no I I'm off work
go after this guy go after mayorkas go
after Joe Biden with everything you've
got
but you got to do it smart and the
question is what are they going to get
mayorcus on
the Democrats during the the Trump
impeachments not just impeachment they
impeach the guy twice they made the
argument that you don't need any legal
basis to impeach somebody it's a purely
political Act
that's not the conservative point of
view Alan dershowitz who is a liberal
though he is
nicer to conservatives than most
liberals Alan dershowitz great Harvard
law professor he pointed out no no you
need a legal basis you to impeach
somebody they have to commit High crimes
or misdemeanors
it's not just that you you don't like
the way they're doing their job Mal
Administration is not a sufficient basis
for impeachment so what are they going
to get mayorcus on is it going to be the
flimsy nonsense that the Democrats try
to impeach Trump over no
it actually very possibly could be
closer to what the Republicans impeached
Clinton over back in the 1990s
since day one says the
the
Republican representative sorry it's
really very confusing here when you're
going through all of the various
articles of impeachment when we've lived
in a time where there have been four
impeachments in 20 years uh since day
one says representative Pat Fallon
secretary mayorkas's policies have
undermined law enforcement activities at
our Southern border from perjuring
himself before Congress and maintaining
operational control of the border to the
infamous whip gate slander against our
border patrol agents secretary mayorkas
has proven time and again that he is
unfit to lead the Department of Homeland
Security okay I totally agree with all
of that and the man obviously is unfit
to lead DHS
but
doing a bad job and being unfit is not a
grounds for impeachment perjury is
don't forget
the Republicans in the 90s did not
impeach Bill Clinton over his
extracurricular activities with his
intern
the
Republicans of the 1990s did not impeach
Bill Clinton because of his eccentric
and imaginative conception of what a
humidor is the Republicans of the 1990s
impeached Bill Clinton for perjury
because he lied
I did not have sexual relations with
that woman
but he did well it depends on what the
meaning of the word is is
I used to be the president yeah right so
slick Willie was able to get out of it
by arguing actually by arguing that he
was a selfish lover when you look down
at the definition of sexual relations
that the Clinton camp and the
investigators were agreeing upon
uh it it gave him a little bit of an out
wherein if he was not uh intending to
provide
sexual satisfaction to his partner his
intern in this case that he maybe could
weasel his way out of saying that he had
sexual relations with that woman at
least that was the argument at the time
and Slick Willie was a really talented
is a really talented politician and was
able to to get out of it
mayorkas is not that so if the
Republicans can get him on perjury good
good on it I know that Joe Biden's just
going to put some other big lib there in
at the border and I know that mayorkas
isn't even the one who's really crafting
the policy that policy is very likely
coming higher up at the level of the
White House doesn't matter go out there
Republicans claim that political scalp
go out there take down one of of Biden's
cabinet secretaries when I think about
what the Trump cabinet secretaries went
down over it is
astounding to me
they got Tom Price on private jets
remember Tom Price the Republican
Secretary of Health and Human Services
he took some private jets this created a
political Scandal he had to resign over
that
and and Trump backed the resignation
absolutely nothing compared to the
egregious activities of the Democrat
cabinet secretary so good on him
Republicans go get them Congress is
throwing its weight around more good
news coming out of the Pentagon now the
Pentagon is ending its vaccine mandate
for servicemen after the House GOP makes
them do it
the dod is ending it because house
Speaker Kevin McCarthy forced an end to
the program last month with the new
National Defense authorization act which
is the annual defense policy and
spending bill that passed and so it's
not that the Pentagon just decided uh
out of the goodness of its heart it's
not that Mark milley there was able to
put down the ibram Kennedy was able to
put down genderqueer by Maya kobabi and
and went in and scrubbed all the purple
out of his hair and and you know got got
rid of some of his piercings and his
pride flags and said you know what now
all of a sudden we're not going to make
you take the fauciology that's not what
happened
what happened was the House GOP forced
the pentagon's hand
what happened was the GOP used political
power
for good effect
and and reminded all of us that it's not
just a completely desperate situation
it's not just the Republicans have
absolutely no power whatsoever it's very
easy to despair in the lingo of the cool
young hip Utes it's very easy to get
black pilled and think that there's just
no chance that we're ever going to have
anything even resembling a conservative
sort of society again
if that were the case the libs would not
be fighting so hard to secure their
power I I think that conservatives
actually can still maintain a little bit
of political power and we can grow it
more if we're willing to exercise it
great example of this down in Florida
Ron DeSantis just
showing the model for what conservative
Governors and frankly what what
conservatives at the federal level
should be doing Ron DeSantis
has just threatened to stop Chinese
Communists from buying real estate in
the United States
my view on the our economy is in Florida
is you know we don't want to have
Holdings uh by hostile Nations and so if
you look at the Chinese Communist Party
they've been very active throughout the
Western hemisphere in gobbling up land
and investing in different things and
you know when when they have interests
that are opposed to ours and you see how
they've wielded their Authority and
especially with President XI who's taken
a a much more Marxist leninist turn
since he's been ruling China that is not
in the best interest of Florida to have
the Chinese Communist Party owning
Farmland owning land close to military
bases but you know my view is and I
think there's a broad agreement in those
two but my view is okay yeah no Farmland
but why would you want them buying
residential developments or things like
that I don't want them owning
subdivisions and things like that I
think that the issue is just going to be
I think people agree with that the issue
is going to be yeah obviously if someone
comes in and buys it's not the CCP
that's signing that these are holding
companies and all that so you got to
structure that in a way that will
effectively police it but yes we do not
need to have CCP influence in Florida's
economy
yes yes oh I just love it I wish I had a
a sort of New Year's Eve blowhorn an
American flag to wave around listening
to that clip this is so beautiful Rhonda
santis totally gets it here and I really
hope this policy goes into effect
because it is going to not only is it
morally and politically astute and right
but it's going to irritate all the right
people
because the limbs are going to go crazy
what do you mean you're taking away our
Chinese Communist influence in America
you can't do that
but it's also going to irritate the
squishes
it's going to irritate the squishes
because the squishes are going to say
well
yeah sure I don't I mean I don't want
the Chinese Communists having political
control over America but
you know what about the free market
what about aren't we supposed to allow
anybody to buy anything that he wants
we're not talking about the Chinese
Communists putting a spy into the
Pentagon and we're just talking about
them buying up some land
so now now the heavy hand of the
centralized government you statists
you run DeSantis you big government
concern you're going to go in and tell
people what they can buy in the free
market yes
and and you know they might even be able
to rationalize themselves okay well
maybe you can put certain limits on how
we operate in the free market if we're
talking about
a political party or a foreign power so
okay maybe I don't know if I love this
because I hate tariffs and I hate all
restrictions on free trade and but all
right uh maybe the CCP cannot buy land
in America okay fine I'm willing to go
there but then Ron DeSantis points out
he says
do you think the Chinese Communists are
are coming in they're going up to
Houlihan Lawrence real estate and
they're saying okay uh yes uh where do I
put chairman xi's signature on the
dotted line you think she is flying over
to him he's saying okay here's the CCP
credit card I want to buy this on behalf
of the Communist party no of course not
the way that the Chinese are buying
land in America and amassing even more
political power than they already have
is through intermediaries through
holding companies through individuals
who are connected to the Communist party
and so DeSantis is saying if we're
actually going to do anything about this
we gotta we gotta put it into effect in
a way that that will be practical
and and he points out actually later in
those comments he says we've already
done this at the universities we've gone
after the Confucius institutes Confucius
institutes are they're not the Chinese
Communist party club
they they have a facade of being purely
academic or purely cultural or not
related but what DeSantis and other GOP
politicians Ted Cruz in particular have
pointed out is no they're just fronts
for the Communist party they should be
banned from the universities let's go
baby wield the heavy hand of the state
to protect our national security
interests
but but just to protect our country it
if we're living in a country right now
and and depending on where you live in
the United States you might be seeing
this directly if we're living in a
country where a hostile foreign power is
coming in and buying up a lot of real
estate that doesn't only present a
national security interest that presents
economic hardship and an upending of the
political order
simply by the fact that they're driving
up real estate prices you got a ton of
money coming out of China coming into
the United States from the party
that is driving up your rent driving up
your mortgage
you see the Santa's theory is saying
yeah of course with the Farmland that
that presents an immediate security
threat but he says why do we want the
Chinese Communists buying residential
property either
it's a reminder and DeSantis gets this
and he's not the only Republican to get
this but he has articulated it in a in a
really powerful way in a really clear
way he understands that
the economy is for the nation
the nation is not for the economy
free market principles
open trade those those can be good
things
but they are a means to an end and the
end is a good country and a flourishing
society and when we put the cart before
the horse then things get a little bit
wonky Rhonda Santos is not a stalinist
okay he's not some heavy-handed big
authoritarian government he's a normal
politician who recognizes that we live
in a republic and Republic comes from
race public that means public things and
he understands that his job is to govern
for the common good of all that's why
states are instituted and that that
doesn't mean confiscating property and
turning us all into commies quite the
opposite he's saying we need to reduce
the power of the Communists and the way
to do that is to wield just political
power that the people have given us
through our form of government really
really great stuff I hope that other
conservatives take note the libs have
dispirited us for so so long they've
made us think well you can you guys can
never wield political power well
DeSantis is showing we can other GOP
politicians are too but DeSantis is
doing it in a really really clear way
it's a new year folks
but leftist companies are still up to
their same old dirty tricks ladies
ladies it is time to help your fellas
wash out the woke once and for all with
Jeremy's Razor's new line of men's
Staples he will love the tea tree and
argon oil infused shampoo and
conditioner if you're watching the show
right now you'll notice I'm in the hotel
room I'm out in Cali filming some
episodes of prageru's book club we had
some really great books coming up but
the only downside
the only downside other than being away
from my family and my children other
than having to be in new Cellini's
hellscape right now where no one has any
freedom the I guess the one of three
downsides is
I don't get to use that Jeremy shampoo I
got to use a stupid Hotel shampoo make
sure you get the shampoo that is
responsible for this quaff that you see
every day they've got the exfoliating
charcoal body wash if your man is a soap
traditionalist who prefer something to
hold on to the oatmeal and citrus soap
scrub maybe you'll hold on to it I don't
know they smell great they're all made
right here in the USA by a Men's
Grooming company that does not hate men
shop the new Jeremy's hair face and body
wash collection and kick woke out of the
bathroom
speaking of racial and ethnic tensions
is upset about how Hollywood casts
people of color and how Hollywood does
not cast people of color but not in the
way that you think
Kumail nanjiani I have seen this name
before I don't really know what he's
been in but I definitely recognize him
as having been in lots of movies and
things
he is very upset because
he wants to play a villain
and he says that Hollywood will not
allow him to play a villain because
Kumail nanjiani as you might be able to
tell from his name is not a white man he
says I think that Hollywood now even
though they're trying to be more diverse
is still weird
and that it's just as limiting as
anything else he says I want to play
more bad guys and then he starts talking
about Sebastian Stan a white friend of
his he says Sebastian Stan does these
big Marvel movies and then he'll play a
psychopath
I was told that's going to be hard for
me because people don't want to cast
non-white people as bad guys
this is true if you've watched movies at
all over the last
30 years 40 years you will notice that
the bad guy always has to be a white guy
and this is why in in James Bond during
the war on terror era
you'll notice James Bond never fought
Osama Bin Laden James Bond the purpose
of the James Bond series is to reflect
in a fun and campy and exciting way
the Chief enemies that we in the west
were fighting
so during the Cold War it was all about
the evil ruskies that's really what it
was about even though they had all these
colorful characters and blofeld and all
the rest of it it was about the Cold War
then the cold war ends in the early 90s
and James Bond is in a new era what are
we going to do who are we really
fighting
and so you get these kind of post-soviet
GoldenEye great James Bond movie these
kind of post-soviet villain types but
then during the war on terror it should
be so clear James Bond is fighting
Muslim terrorists
except he could
he couldn't because of political
correctness
the only the nearest thing to a person
of color that Hollywood will allow
to become a villain
it's the Russians Russians are the are
the people of color of the white people
and so Russians are allowed to be the
villains Eastern Europeans they're kind
of but that's it that's the closest you
can get and I am totally sympathetic to
what Kumail nanjani is saying here what
he's saying is this is dehumanizing and
it is it is just as dehumanizing as
saying that a Indian guy can't be the
good guy or that a black guy can't be
the good guy
it is just as dehumanizing to say that a
black guy can't be the bad guy but
that's why the way forget about
Hollywood for a second that is the way
that our entire culture operates now
if there is a heinous crime committed a
school shooting or something like that
if the school shooter is a white guy you
are going to see that right at the top
of the news report
20 year old angry white man probably
radicalized by the far right-wing people
on the internet he this white why are
white men so angry he's just committed
this horrible crime if it's a black guy
who could for a school shooting or
whatever any any kind of attack it will
always say 18 year old man
there's no the race is never mentioned
this is how actually when you read the
news reports about any crime if the race
is not mentioned you can almost 100 of
the time bet that the attacker is not
white
it's just a it's just a way that the
news operates if they can make the white
guy the villain they will if they can't
they'll leave race out of it altogether
and that is dehumanizing I I would
always talk about this when when I
brought up Christopher Columbus
or when when someone raised the the
issue of the pilgrims and the early
Americans and what we did to those poor
Native Americans
when people would propose this
Pocahontas view not the Elizabeth Warren
View and not the actual story of
Pocahontas but you know the Disneyland
kind of view of the indigenous people
that were all the Avatar of you they
were all just living in accord with
nature playing their drums singing
Kumbaya dancing around with the does and
the deer all through until the evil
white man came and he upset this
wonderful balance of nature they were
basically these indigenous people they
were living they were Immortals in
eudenic paradise and then the white man
came and spoiled despoiled at all and
now there's sin and death that pervades
that's not what happened
that's not what happened
it is just as absurd to say that the
Native Americans
could not be bad in any way
as to say that the Native Americans
could not be good in any way
stay human these are people when you
look at the real story of the Mayflower
and the early the pilgrims and the early
Americans in New England it's much more
interesting than the idea that they
showed up and they gave everybody
smallpox blankets and they killed off
all the Indians and took their corn
that's not what happened
the the Indians there I'm specifically
thinking of people like massasoet I'm
specifically thinking of people like his
progeny King Philip I'm specifically
thinking of the the Massachusetts
Indians I'm thinking of the Algonquin
Indians I'm thinking about all of the
different tribes around there they were
crafty they were smart especially our
buddy Master saw it they were tacticians
and strategists NASA so it used the
pilgrims to grow his political control
all around the region and had had his
progeny King Philip not screwed
everything up because he misinterpreted
how his brother died they probably could
have lived together in relative peace
for a much longer period of time
he's a real man
when when massasoa decided to
side with the pilgrims against the
Massachusetts he was making a political
decision and it was it was a smart
political decision as far as I'm
concerned
they're humans too and humans are not
just humans can be bad guys
even Indian people even even black
people can be bad guys but it's identity
politics all the way down in our culture
this is a story I'd been meaning to get
to I'm glad we finally have time
breaking news if you're driving please
pull over if you're standing up please
sit down Mars candy will be releasing
all female packs of M M's
yes finally
how
how is the candy female I well the way
that the candy's female is that they've
got those little cartoons that they put
in the commercials and some of the
cartoons are men and some of the
cartoons are women this this issue
actually came up about a year ago
because uh M Ms announced that the green
m m was no longer going to be sexy
previously the green m m was really
really hot and sexy as far as candy
coated chocolates go and then they
decided they were going to make the
green m m kind of frumpy and sexually
ambiguous so okay
going with the culture I guess uh but
now now they're saying okay we're going
to release all female packs
and why are they doing that because they
want to quote celebrate women everywhere
who are flipping the status quo and it's
really funny because the pack actually
just shows these women upside down these
women hanging by their feet completely
upside down it doesn't seem very
celebratory to me but what does it tell
you about the culture
what this it the Eminem story actually
does tell you something about the
culture we're living in it tells you
that our culture today is glib gay and
contemptuous of our forebears that's
what it is this is so glib so much of
our activism of our real political
discourse in this country
is putting the chick M Ms in the bag
that's how we're going to seriously deal
with the moral and political issues of
our time we're going to post a black
Square on Instagram yeah that's right
you know what we're gonna do we're gonna
start a hashtag yes Michelle Obama
well she was first lady of the United
States well her president was the most
powerful man in the world
posted on social media a picture of
herself holding up a white sheet of
paper that said hashtag bring back our
girls
frat and she was frowning she looked
very serious
because Boko Haram a terrorist group had
kidnapped a bunch of girls said Bring
Back Our Girls
her husband's the president
if if he wanted to get rid of Boko Haram
he could do it in two seconds Boko Haram
they don't I don't think they have a
nuclear weapons I don't think they're
the most sophisticated or civilized
people in the world
they're a thug terror group
of of people using very old Weaponry who
could be wiped out by the US military in
a morning before lunch
but for any number of reasons Barack
Obama didn't want to go take out Boko
Haram so how are we going to stop it
we're going to hold up hashtags do we
ever get Kony 2012
are we there yet
I'm not so sure very glib culture and a
gay culture and I'm using gay in a
technical sense of that term not to mean
that it's a happy culture it's not a
happy culture but gay meaning we don't
recognize that men need women and women
need men we don't recognize that we
don't recognize that men and women are
complementary our culture views men and
women alternately as identical and
indiscernible
and as in opposition to one another the
old expression used to be that you will
never have a war between the sexes in
this country because everybody is
Sleeping with the Enemy
increasingly that's not so true 20 plus
percent of gen Z identifies as lgbtq so
I don't know maybe you will get a gender
war in the country
it's glib it's gay and it's contentious
of our forebears congratulations to
women for flipping the status quo what's
wrong with the status quo I got plenty
of problems with the status quo because
of how it has upended our our
millennia-long traditions in recent
decades that's my issue with the status
quo but most people's issue on the lit
on the left with the status quo is that
anything that happened in the past
is really bad and evil anything that's
happening right now is a crisis and it's
pretty bad and evil and anything that
happens in the future is going to be
better than the present and the past
that is a culture that is in serious
decline that is a culture I hope it's
not terminal decline but it's a culture
that's given up the the most important
democracy in the world that's the
Democracy of the Dead that does not
merely combine uh the the decisions
about how we live to the people who
happen to be walking on on the earth at
the present moment but actually looks to
the Past receives wisdom recognizes that
maybe we don't know every single thing
that's ever been discovered maybe maybe
a span of 80 years is not enough time to
learn everything that there is to learn
maybe we ought to have a little respect
for history in the Great Men Who came
before us no our culture says no Enjoy
your M M's the member block starts right
now uh this is uh I don't I don't have a
pun for today what is today Thursday
this is
there's a story that I wanted to get to
Thursday
and by which I mean my producer Ben
Davies that's not a good pound if you
can think of a better pun please let me
know in the comments my producer Ben
Davies has a story every week that he's
upset that I don't get to and so I've
got the story here facing upside down I
will flip it over and read the story for
the first time you got to go to the
member block to do that okay that is
dailywire.com Knowles use code nulls at
checkout you will get two months free on
all annual plans see at the member block
[Music]
foreign
[Music]